Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And welcome to "Riddle School 2!"
Now, I know it's been a while since I played the first Riddle School
And I meant to get back to this a lot sooner
Uh, but things got in the way, and then I totally forgot about the series
And I meant to do the whole series with all the different games in it...
And even Riddle's... Transfer games...?
*thud*
Oh, he's bored, okay
(Quiet voice)
Welcome to "Riddle School 2"
Ah...
Oh...
What is this?
I love the pun on the wall over there, but I'm not sure why we're here...
Man, that guy is twitchy and sad.
Ahh!
Coins! :3
Good! :D Are these things that I need?
Hi, Teacher!
How you doin'?
"That's the band director, Mr. O. Boe...."
"He only got hired because-us-us his name."
Okay. :3
""Cold." What's that about?"
"I know nothing of music, but much of english."
That doesn't help anybody.
"Hey, Phred, can you help me escape school again?"
"I have a whistle, as if that'd be useful."
"It might help, can I have it?"
"Only if you have a dollar."
I almost have a dollar!
I got 75 cents!
Is there another quarter hiding up in the notes up there?
Maybe a QUARTER NOTE!
*Bouncing* Ha-ah-ah-ah ah-ahah!!
*inception bwang*
Now that we're off to an incredible start, let's go outside.
"Not while Mr. O. Boe. is watching!"
Okay, so there's gotta be another quarter up here!
It's gotta be hiding in the quarter notes!
It can't just be a pun, it has to actually be a thing, right?
No?
NO?
NO?!
Oh, there it is. It was on the drum set, okay.
I gotta dollar! :D
Thanks!
Well shit!
What did it do to the poor guy?
Did it kill him?!
Is he dead?! D:
Why is everybody dead?!
Why did he freeze?
Aw, happy man's not so happy anymore...
Okay! Bye everybody who's been incapacitated!
"Now that was a SHARP idea!"
...I don't get that.
Mrs. Sleep?
Ohh...
"Isn't that interesting? She stopped at the letter "Z"."
"Mrs. Sleep, she hasn't moved since last month."
She might be dead.
"Until we drag someone to--"
"--find someone to drag her out of the room and replace her, she's here to stay."
"It's kinda boring, but at least we don't have to do any work."
Ooookay...
It's in sleep mode? That's very funny. I don't feel
Bluuuuueee
Ooookay.....
Ahhhh!
Okay!
Some trombone slide oil
And 30 cents...
I don't know what you're gonna do with that mixture,
But it sounds like a fun time, I suppose.
"Can't get out."
Yeah, no joke, you can't.
"Counselor has these keys like last time."
Oh... :c
Okay then.
Not going back in there, exactly?
So what am I going to do with all this trombone lube?
Oh.
Hi.
Hellooo
I seem to remember we being in a...
similar precarious situation before.
"What are you doing here?"
W-what are YOU DOING THERE IN THE CLOSET JUST STANDING BY YOURSELF?
Not really good
Office?
"Mr. Sum..."
Light's are off, doors locked.
He's probably masturbating.
Lets see- Water..
Doing something about that...
I dont brake for ducks, there arent many ducks.
How 'bout the womens bathroom
NO?
Whynaught?
Doors locked, lights are off..
Mens room?
"Anybody have any toilet paper?"
uhh..
No?
I dont have any.
Lets see, these things are backed uep..
OkAy, nothing to do in here.
How about some slide oil?
You could lube up your pooper :3
I dunno why that would help you in any capacity but, its just something that I said
Oohkay.
Got another quarter.
Oh no, thats just dime I got.
Got 40 cents.
Nuh-I checked all the other lockers, and they dont seem to do anything so i'll head over-
Hello.
"I want a cookie."
Well I dont have anything this time!
Okay.
Wow, they made a second one? Okay.
Well, I wont need that.
"Back door unlocked but its blocked by dumpster.."
Okay, Teachers lounge?
Why are you in here?
Let's see.
*reading choices*
I SAW A COW THAT BURST INTO FLAMES! IT WAS NUTS!
CRAZY!
"Was it my cow? What did it look like?" D:
Uh.
Fat, white with black spots?
oh okay
nvm den
Damn it, I almost had that.
lessee
Burst into flames.
"That doesn't convince me, unless the story's true"
It did believe- sound
" It didn't sound that believable to begin with."
"If you dont have anything useful-" Aww..
So the cow bursting into flames isnt good?
"Which teacher sent you here?
Uhhh...
No teacher, just the cookie machine
ok nvm den
So this is actually gonna be a conundrum.
Mr. (el) O. Bow!
Okay.
How 'bout Ms. Sleep?
Got permission.
Ms. Sleep?
Okay, Mr. Sum?
"That's me" ? Oh, okay
Alright, geez this isn't working then.
Alright.
Lets see.
Alright, FINE, theres gotta be a solution here!
Oops! Wrong room! Ah, fuck.
Gotta be a waaaay!
Okay, so I gotta get a note..
What I gotta do is go get a note from the band room.
How 'bout the janitor?
You want some slide oil? :3
Awww, okay :(
Wait, theres a roll of toilet paper in the vent?
How does that make any sense??
"I would go in and get it but the vent cover is rusted shut."
Well, it's a good thing I got some good ol' fashion TROMBONE OIL!
Dunno how that beats rust but I lubed it up good and slid right in between the cracks.
Alright, lets deliver toilet paper to this guy here.
There ya go buddy! Could've rolled it under...
A-wOOSH.
What are you doin'? Okay bye.
No thanks or nothing.
Yeah okay.
I got a mop.
Do I give this back to the janitor because somehow he... loses his shit?
How 'bout a mop? "Where'd you find my mop?"
For some reason, it was in the toilet.
"Thanks for returning it, here's my last dime."
Well now I have 50 cents
"and don't waste it on those school's cheesy pencils"
That doesn't help me at all!
Wait
I don't have enough money for a cookie!
How'm I gonna- ooohhh
Wait a minute. Whatayou doin' back here?
You were in the teacher's lounge
"Have a nice visit...hurry back when you're finished"
Okkaaayyy...
*fading voice* Can't see why I need it [inaudible]. I'm a little confused
Okay so he's back
And she's back.
So that means that in some of these- in this room,
There's gotta be like a quarter or something in one of these rooms
and then I gotta find it and then its gonna help me...
get the cookie because the cookie is 75 cents according to the thing on the teachers lounge
AHHH, there we go, found it, okay I got 75 cents now right?
That's enough to be able to get a cookie?
That's enough to be able to- ho-how am I supposed to do this?
Do I need to lube up the cookie machine?
I got 75 cents right?
Goddammit
Huh
Okay, now this is a conundrum and I don't know how to solve it
OOHHH
Oh
Well that was- How was I supposed to know that?
There was literally no way that I would've known that!
Oh man I hate that! That's like my least favourite thing about these puzzle games
When you have to click at like the back of something.
But either way, I got it! I GOT IT!
Bablabamlabamalabamlabam
Okay blam. I blam-ed it to blam-o
And I gotta cookie!
Hey big guy! You wanna cookie?!
I gotta cookie for ya! I've also got some lube if you want that...
I have- I have a whole handful of lube!
Wow, that was fast!
Okay. Hello. 'That's 5'
'Yes that's his name'
'He won election'... 'vote 5' okay
Happy face
Bowling ball
Cabinets unlocked. Hello!
Somebody in here? Hi Mr. Mister
How you doin'? May I leave the school?
Oh *laughs* Alright, bye then!
Sucker! - 'I think he took the key'
Okay
Goodbye!?
Am I outta here? OOOHHH
That's all she wrote!
That was o-, Oh, oh no
Oh yes, okay, we're okay
K'chunk - You put it in upside down but I won't criticize you about that
*deep inhale* FREEEDOMMMM
OHHH YEESSS!
GLORIOUSSS FREEDDOMM!!
Okay, so that's the end of 'Riddle School 2'
There's a whole buncha other r- riddle school games
and I'll say basically the same thing as I said in the last one:
These are fun little adventures and its like- its like a time capsule
- I don't know if I said this in the last one. I'm just making it up as I go -
But it's like a time capsule, going through the series...
I imagine, I've act- never played it before but...
but its like a time capsule going through and seeing like the...
the evolution of the designer of the game and also like the evolution of technology as it goes along and like...
and the complexity getting more and more things so
its a really fun series with a lot of like... PUNS!...
which if you like that you get a lot of that in your life so...
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Lemme know if you wanna see the other games in the series in the comments below...
and thanks again for watching
And as always...
I will see YOU in the next video...
Bu-Bye!!